[Arabic recitation]
verse number 31. In this verse, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us about
the reasons that he mentions particular
and specific
details
that would seem at first glance to be
out of place.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has very
strategically
mentioned particular details.
And this one detail that he mentions in
a verse here or there will act as an
agent to help those who are already
believers and to further impede those
who are already disbelievers. As we will
hear in this verse,
for
[Silence]
Menithdu.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he told us in the verse before it verse
number 30
that the hellfire has 19
angels that are commissioned as the
gatekeepers
and those that run and regulate the
hellfire and its people. 19 all of these
19 work under the command of Malik
Alisam.
Malik is the name of the angel that is
the chief gatekeeper of the hellfire.
Do we know the name of the chief
gatekeeper of paradise?
The name of the chief gatekeeper of
paradise is as is mentioned in some
narrations of the prophet Sam
and Sah Muslim
excuse me in Bkari in the chapter
regarding the interpretation of
dreams
the prophet sallall.aii mentions
a very long narration
in which he says
he said last night
two men came to me in my dream in my
sleep in a vision
and they woke me up and they said to me
come with us. And it's a very long
narration, but
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
shown many things in this experience.
And one of the things that he said he
saw was a man who was very stern in his
facial expression. He was very stern and
harsh and he was
you know he was inflaming the
hellfire and he was circling around it
and monitoring it and tending to it. And
at the end of the narration, we find out
that these two men that came to him were
Gibl and Mikimatam.
And he tells us that this man that you
saw that was so stern and very angry and
very harsh, that is Malik, the
gatekeeper and chief gatekeeper of the
hellfire.
And so his name is Malik.
However, under him work many angels.
And 19 of these angels report to Malik
Alam.
And under these 19, there could be
millions of other angels that work.
However, these 19 are the chief
gatekeepers of the hellfire.
Now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioned
this number 19.
Why this number? Why is this number so
important? We've learned elsewhere in
the Quran that the gates of hell are
seven
and 19 does not divide
you know completely and and equally
on the seven gates of hell.
And we don't have a narration of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam or other
verses of the Quran
that explain to us exactly why it is 19
or how they are divided and how their
workload is divided. We don't know that
exactly. We don't know which angels tend
to which layer or which gate of the
hellfire. But what we know is they are
19. And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentioned this number and he mentioned
this description of hell for a number of
reasons. He explains to us those some of
those wisdoms and some of those reasons
in verse number 31. He says subhanahua
and we have not appointed
to be the gatekeepers of the hellfire
except angels. So we know that angels
are the agents which Allah has placed
and commissioned with regulating the
hellfire. And this is a response to Abu
Jah and others of the mushri
who started to mock the prophet
sallall.aii
when Allah revealed the earlier verse of
19.
And so when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said about the hellfire
and others said
meaning I will take care of them 19 men
I can handle 10 of them myself you guys
handle the rest in different narrations
and we will push past them and we can
overtake the hellfire itself. This is
what they said. And Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said as a rebuttal
that these are not just regular men.
These are angels that have been designed
and commissioned by Allah to regulate
the hellfire and subject to incredible
torture. the people who are there and
the damned souls that are handed over to
them. He says,
he said, "And we have not made their
number of 19 and mention this detail
except as to act as an impediment to the
disbelievers. those who have already
chosen to disbelieve
this number and this seemingly out
ofplace detail. It will only act as a
justification
for those who have already chosen
disbelief to become more extent in their
disbelief.
And another reason we have made their
number 19. And we have commissioned them
as angels
and mention this detail in the Quran so
as to act as a reinforcement and an
evidence for the people of the book that
the Quran is truly from Allah and is
given to his messenger Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam. Why is that?
Because in the previous books Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioned this
detail in the or the he gave to Misam
and
why did Allah mention this detail to
Benny is benu is
are known for asking a lot of questions
and details that are not beneficial to
them. Right? So Ben is
the people of Misam that were with him,
the people of Isa, when Allah would send
down a verse speaking about something or
inform him of something, they would ask
a lot of petty questions as Allah is
mentioned through the Quran.
So for instance, Allah will mention
a story of one of the prophets,
the story of Adamisam
and the tree and that he ate from the
fruit of the tree that was forbidden.
Instead of them looking at the lesson
behind that, which is
eating from the tree, the action, what
they were prohibited, what the moral of
the story is, they will want their minds
go to. Well, what kind of tree was it?
What kind of fruit was it? Was it just
one tree or was it a type of tree that
was all through the paradise? Right.
Misam
had a staff. They would ask what kind
what kind of wood was it made out of?
How long was it? What was the shape of
his staff? The people of the cave. How
many were there? Was it six or seven or
eight or nine? And they had a dog. What
breed was that dog? Or was it a mud? Was
it a mixture? Did it have a pure book
bloodline?
How tall was this one? How tall was was
Jalut? and how big was Talut? Right?
These kinds of questions that not only
have nothing to do with the
with the story really, but they
detract
from the moral of the story. They
detract from the moral of the story. Why
does this matter? It has nothing to do
with the benefit that is taken from this
story. They're just asking questions
a child unfettered and his mind
wandering to the most obscure and
unnecessary things. And this is how they
dealt not only with stories but they
dealt this way also with their own
messengers
with their own prophets. And they dealt
this way even with commands that were
given to them. So when Musam said
Allah commands that you slaughter a cow.
What did they do? They didn't say,
"Okay, grab the nearest cow and
slaughter that cow." No. If they did
that, it would have been fine. That's
exactly what was asked of them. Instead,
what what kind of how old is this cow?
Is it an older cow or a younger cow?
Male or female? What color is the cow?
Matter of fact, what does the cow do? Is
it a working cow or is it a cow for
milk? Or is it what kind of cow is it?
Right? And so they're asking these
questions and why is this disobedience?
Because it articulates that number one,
they're not taking it seriously. And
number two, they don't want to do it.
If they wanted to do it, they would do
it immediately.
But they don't want to do it. So because
they don't want to do it, they start to
ask these detracting questions. Right? I
want to give you an example.
Imagine for instance that you told your
son or your daughter, "Go get me a glass
of water." And you know he's laying down
on his back or he's sitting on a chair
or playing a video game. We say, "Go get
me a glass of water, boy." And he says,
"What kind of glass? Do you want it in
plastic or glass?" And give me a glass
of water and a glass. How full do you
want it? You want it all the way full, a
quarter full, half, a quarter? Do you
want cold water or hot water? Do you
want the water to be this or that? Do
you want me to do this with it or that
with it? What kind What color glass do
you want? We have different colors,
right? and continues to ask you these
questions while he's playing his video
game, what would you understand from
this kind of exchange,
he doesn't want to do it. Obviously, he
doesn't want to do it. He wants you to
finally say, "Okay, you know what?
Forget about it." Right? And this is
exactly the attitude that Benu is took
with Misam
and their subsequent messengers. And so
it's not surprising that we would have
such an obscure detail 19 being the
gatekeepers of the hellfire because Benu
is were known to ask about these kinds
of things. And so it is in their books
but that is also an anchor for this
book. It bolsters this book because that
is a very obscure detail and Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam has no way
of knowing that if he is not a prophet
and a messenger because not even all of
the scholars of Benny is perhaps know
that particular detail. And so when
Allah mentions this in the Quran, this
now is an evidence that he is not
speaking from himself. This is actually
the Quran that was revealed to him by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and that he is
in fact a messenger. And so the Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says here
[Silence]
and we have only made their number known
as 19 to act as an impediment, a further
impediment for the one who has already
chosen to disbelieve. Why? Because when
he hears that he'll say, "What kind of a
silly number is that? What does that
even mean? Why 19? What's the point of
that?" Right? This is clearly just
ramblings from Muhammad. So now this
this statement,
it acts as a further impediment for the
disbelievers because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala wants to separate truth from
falsehood. He doesn't want the
disbeliever and the believer to be very
close and equal. He wants the
disbeliever to continue to be further in
his disbelief
just he desires of the believer to
be more excellent in his belief. And so
he will send down a verse or a chapter
of the Quran that will act as an
impediment for the disbeliever and
simultaneously an evidence for the
people of the book and simultaneously
a reason for the true believers to be
increased in their faith. He says
him.
[Silence]
Wow.
And also we have made their number known
so as to increase those who already
believe in their belief.
He says,
And we have made their number known in
order that the people of the book and
the believers
are in order for them to become secure
in their faith and have no doubts as to
the origins of the Quran. He says,
[Silence]
He says, "And we have made their number
known in order that those who have
sickness and disease in their hearts
and the disbelievers
in order for them to be increased in
their confusion and say to themselves,
"What is Allah trying to get at by
saying these things?" Meaning, if this
is if this book is truly from Allah, why
would he mention stuff this? And
why would he use these as the as his
parables as opposed to other more
significant issues? And this is deeply
rooted in the belief of the of the
mushri
prior to Islam which we will expound
upon tomorrow night inshallah
every night Sunday
Wednesday
those four days we are continuing in
taps of the Quran according to the order
of revelation. So right now we are in
the verse number 31
of surah
which is the 74th chapter of the Quran.
It will behoove you all
to at least read these verses every
night. five or six verses that we are
going to speak about every night before
you come to
or even better that you read along even
if only on your phones as we go through
these verses because this knowledge will
only stick if you have already memorized
these verses or are able to see them.
Otherwise, it's kind of disconnected and
just in the air. In order for you to be
able to follow along properly and
understand and keep the knowledge that
you gain every night, it will behoove
you all to follow along and read
these verses. Even try to memorize them
before. If you could imagine memorizing
10 or 12 verses every week,
within a few years you will have
memorized the entirety of the Quran. If
a person amongst us memorized one verse
a day, one verse, just one, one verse a
day, within 10 years, every one of us
would be a of the Quran. And I know that
many of us have been Muslim for far
longer than 10 years. And so this is the
thing that even water dripping onto
stone will carve it out. I'll mention
this one thing and we will end with
this. One of the scholars of hadith
and this story was mentioned by Ibar and
others in his book Fatal and elsewhere.
He was a student of hadith and he was
studying for months and months with his
teacher.
He was unable to keep up with his peers
and he was unable after this time he
spent to
you know to organize the knowledge in
his head and to retain the knowledge he
was learning. He felt he had a weak
memory. He felt he couldn't keep up
with his peers and so he was with his
sheh for many months and he decided to
give up. He said I I'm just not cut out
for this. I'm going to go and learn some
trade or something and I am going to end
this journey of every day going to seek
knowledge and I'm unable to retain it
and after all this hard work I haven't
reached anywhere. And so as he left on
his way, he passed by
a kind of waterfall coming down off of a
mountain. And he saw that there was
water that was dripping from above onto
another slab of rock.
And this slab of rock that was being the
water was dripping onto had carved out
into the rock where this drip was
dropping down every day. And he saw this
and he noticed that this must have been
going on for years. Maybe this has been
going on for 50 years, a hundred years,
maybe more where this every
minute this one drop of water and it
has been able to carve out this stone.
He says,
He
bech.
[Silence]
He said to himself, "This water as soft
and gentle as it is and this stone as
hard as it is,
because of the time it has been able to
carve out this stone, knowledge is not
more gentle. gentle than this water and
my heart is not more hard than this
stone. And he went back and he really
rolled his sleeves up and every time he
would start to feel those emotions of of
boredom or those emotions of giving up
again, he would remember what he saw
that day. And he continued to study and
he became one of the major of the
which are mentioned and referred to even
to this day.
We tried to always keep these talks
except for Saturday down to 20 minutes
between 17 and 20 minutes. In the
morning we have 10 minutes. So if you
join us for the morning and for the
evening, you will have spent half an
hour collectively in the knowledge of
the Quran and the Sunnah
in the morning in the evening.
sometimes we go a little bit over like
we did tonight. However, keep in mind
that knowledge is earned slowly and over
time and you have to put in the work.
You have to concentrate. You have to
think. You have to go out of your way to
learn. I'm trying as hard as I can to
spoon feed as best as I can. But there
has to be reciprocity. The more you take
it seriously, the more knowledge will
give you of itself.
Alhamdulillah.